just got a call from the Starbucks by
red arrow Park I say there's almost kind
of sleep in everyone in China it's
blackmail 30 to 40 years old
12:46 146 shots fired shots fired
officer involved one person is shot to
kill by Milwaukee police in the heart of
downtown Milan chief says the suspect
grabbed the officers baton and started
beating him with an understand that this
is the initial version of events today
is the grand opening tea party for the
mother's ward justice circle so for now
I'll just put it there I'm going to be
introduced to the mothers that are going
through the same type of pain I am
okay I still got my days I still have my
nights and it's been 15 years right
you know her son was shot 14 times I was
shot seven your Yahoo was shot six
that's why I'm here and I thank God that
I'm here you know
dontre was my brilliant child he never
showed any signs of any kind of paranoid
or schizophrenic he was normally had a
driver's license he paid it all bills we
start seeing signs when he would say
things like did you eat it you don't
leave that on April 30th
dontre went to riddle park something
that he frequently did throughout his
life he was sitting in the park and the
manager at Starbucks called the police
to have dontre removed because she
thought he was a homeless man the first
code the police officers answered her
calling and came out and they had the
discussion with RA and they went and
told her they found that he wasn't doing
anything wrong
when the call came to dispatch it went
to Christopher manney the beat cop and
they kind of got into back and forth
words to the point where the officer
grabbed his baton out Shrugged actually
a couple times with the time time very
ticked at the time and from there you
gonna have the officer stand it dr. a
struck them you have witnessed sanded
dontre never heard hit the officer we
were told that Christopher manney
jumped to try to retrieve the / time
from dontre and he missed and he pulled
his gun out and he shot my baby 14 times
I sat on the couch for two months and I
believe the old two months I was in
shock I felt like I had nothing and I
felt a long there saying that
dontre was homeless and he just crazy
just a frantic and that's why he was shy
thou art with me thy rod and thy staff
they comfort me
thou prepareth the table before me in
the presence of mine
all right you said my son pushed him now
he hit him in his head I was like we
don't know if that's true that's only
two people know then who and have one of
them is dead right they're killing
people that don't have weapons all they
have to say is I feared for my life
after they murder people these are the
ones that died this year I found out
that justice wasn't served in any of
these cases and it was overwhelming
all right thank you sweetheart it was
good hearing from you and I'm praying
for you and and be sure I'm the founder
of mothers for justice United I decided
to name this Morris the Million Moms
smarts not really expecting it to get as
big as it has tell you a little bit
about the trip we're leaving here we're
going to Washington DC May night May 9th
is my birthday
and that's ray was buried on May 9th
Maria Hamilton is the main organizer and
will lead a Mother's Day march that will
take place Saturday of this week and
they're going to be meeting with people
in the White House you have been
incredible at calling people to
accountability organizing other mothers
meeting these moms and doing the
research brought me to this place that
I'm at I'm not sure if I lost a child in
such a terrible violent way if I would
have the courage or the strength I just
want to praise you ladies for having the
courage to speak up
I also personally believe that there
should be some form of a civilian panel
yes that is involved as well we're
headed she talked to staffers about
police brutality and vigilante killings
so nervous were going to give them out
demand a national call for the DOJ to
help special prosecutors people that do
not have any kind of links to the police
officers or the DA's office hopefully we
can get cases reopened and possibly get
justice for their kids life
we didn't do the script that was
proposed this is life this is reality
the voice that we gave today it might
have been crying but I think they heard
it's tough because everybody seemed like
they just wanted to break down at any
given second and then I think once we
left I think they don't cry
I have post-traumatic stress disorder I
take medication to keep the fresh bags
away - my son was shot and killed in my
home and my face in front of me and my
daughter there Brooke had told the tears
you the shoot eat tenth time I've been
trying to piece together exactly
it is so many moms that didn't feel
anybody care that have joined forces
with us and there's no stuff in there
we're sitting here waiting and while
we're waiting more babies are dying
there's so much violence and it needs to
stop no one deserves the way dr. I and I
learn how to fight I will be back here
every year to make sure that these
police officers that are taking human
life go do
yeah it could have it could have been
mine that's the sentiment of the
president
let's assist that's the fulfilling of
attorney general doctrine is bigger than
life
I am rapping I see him with his great
Jordans but what I enjoyed most is a
smile we are considering stars some
others for justice chapters all over the
United States I want to have a national
organization
I'm determined to get change so mother's
for justice gives me hope
that I was pregnant I gotta get my
prenatal pills so we went to Rite Aid
the Caucasian man walks up pushes
Dante's into a show and